there's such a packed program for you
today that there's really no time to
waste for me telling you this is a great
show today we might record this one
today we might actually save this one
today because the show is so packed that
it would be a disservice given the huge
news I have to discuss with you to spend
time talking about the show in a sort of
meta sense and so I'm not going to do
that I'm not going to talk about the
show we're just going to do the show
okay and at the top we have to talk
about the collapsing polling numbers for
Democrats not only in the house we knew
the house was probably lost but also the
Senate and there are a couple of
different suspicions I have about why
this is happening let's reset
historically in general one party wins
the White House first midterm it goes
very poorly for that party Bill Clinton
won the White House in 1992
1994 historic defeat by Republicans in
which Newt Gingrich Republican comes to
power as Speaker of the House and
significantly moves the Republican party
uh away from Reagan and towards Trump in
a story that we've told many times
before an exception to this was in uh
2000 and 2002 George W bush Republican
winning in 2000 Republicans actually
doing okay in 2002 considered
extenuating circumstances lead up to the
Iraq War Post 9 11 Etc but generally
we would expect Democrats to do poorly
in November
that being said it looked as though
Democrats were clearly going to keep
control of the senate in fact there was
a close to 70 percent chance according
to the 538 forecast that that indeed
would happen that has changed the Senate
at this point is basically a coin flip
it's a coin flip with like a slightly
heavier head side so it's like 55-45
that in fact those are the exact numbers
right now if you look at the 538
forecast it is a 45 percent chance that
Republicans take the Senate 55 chance
that Democrats win and if you scroll
down the 538 forecast page which we are
linking to you see the change
you see how the forecast has changed and
you see that after peaking right above
70 odds for Democrats in mid-september
it has been a slow collapse and then a
rapid collapse all the way to what is
now basically a coin flip now if we look
at the house Democrats were never
favored to keep the house but it didn't
look this grim and unfortunately the
range now of outcomes is with
Republicans just barely taking the house
by one seat all the way to Republicans
holding a nearly 40-seat majority
Democrats now have a 19 chance of
holding the house and if you look at how
those numbers have changed over time
uh sorry here it is you also see that
there was a similar inflection point at
which point it became a sort of two to
one disadvantage for Democrats in late
September it is now down to a one in
five shot for Democrats adding on to the
not particularly good news a court has
temporarily blocked Joe Biden's student
loan forgiveness which was one of the uh
actions that Joe Biden
um took which was booing Democrats and
improving odds for November so what is
going on here there's basically two
major stories here that I would point to
number one it is absolutely the case
that when the Supreme Court overturned
Roe v Wade
given that Americans support Roe v Wade
by a greater margin than at any point in
the Roe v Wade era that there was anger
there was Anger from men there was Anger
from women there was there was anger
about that decision because it is after
all a right-wing activist Supreme Court
at this time and there was renewed
interest in voting and there was energy
behind listen if this is what these
Republicans are going to do we've got to
elect some Democrats
the timing of that energy seems to be
dissipating and when you now ask people
what are the most important issues they
say economy and they say inflation Etc
so the the analogy I used over the
weekend on a live stream was if you are
getting ready for you know a big test at
school and you say I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna have a quadruple Express
espresso Express I almost said the thing
Express no I'm gonna have a quadruple
espresso uh and I'm going to be all
fired up and ready to go and you take
the espresso too early and your energy
Peaks an hour before the test and then
by the time the test starts the espresso
is wearing off you've mistimed The Surge
of energy
and that is the analogy to what I think
happened here with Roe v Wade now the
timing wasn't up to us the Supreme Court
had its timing and I believe that that
is one fact uh one factor the other side
is that Democratic messaging has not
been very good and later we're going to
look at a clip from Gavin Newsom who
says the most dangerous states by by
crime rates are all red States and yet
we've let Republicans take over the
narrative and say violent Democrat
States violent Democrat States that's
just one example but I do think the
messaging from Democrats has continued
to be terrible and the messaging from
Republicans has continued to be
effective so those are two major factors
it's really not looking good do we give
up of course not I mean listen if you
live in Pennsylvania you get to vote for
the Senate you get to vote for the
governor and other local races
you might as well do it and then we see
what happens but the numbers overall
from a 30 000 foot standpoint
are looking increasingly bad for
Democrats and that is very bad for the
country because of the delusional
extreme nature of the modern Republican
party and by the way they're also
starting to intimidate voters let's talk
about that next